kiss me this side the side the side
please kiss me princess hmm really
you doing this to me I BuzzFeed from
Jackson women from China and I'm meeting
the puppies they taught me the puppy to
because I'm the you're the dog let's go
all girls her name will be sugar and
this would be snow white oh my god it
has been a long time since I play with
puppies I really want to adopt but oh I
feel like I can't even take care of
myself oh my god
oh what's the question is where are you
going to release team wearing
merchandise probably like August
September they're gonna be hats hoodies
t-shirts phone case long coat scarf yeah
a lot a slippers cookies is here is here
is here is here smart oh if you can't
get a tattoo what would it be all my
parents birthday my mum's birthday here
not the dad's birthday here and probably
like my son like at the back if I have a
son or a daughter my princess hi person
what's your ideal first date
Oh Oh is she peeing
don't eat that come here come here I do
a first date I'll probably take her to
dinner in the Chinese restaurant hotpot
if you could transform into any animal
what would it be puppy getting a lot of
love
what is your creative process like when
it comes to making music want to produce
music it's just let that vibe come to me
instead of like me going after them when
it comes it comes if you had the chance
to act in a movie or a drama what kind
of role would you like to play agent
mission impossible we're back on that
character noting romance I'm not into I
can't do that like it's just not my
thing
what are you doing don't fight
okay I'll tell you to come here well you
come here 200 what can anybody get like
get my questions favorite fashion piece
Fendi slippers can can you get that for
me please
bottom bottom bottom what is one song
that you think represents you the best
oh my god
if any man who's an artist that you
really want to collaborate with
Omarion when did you realize you're
famous I'm not if you could have any
superpower what power would it be
visible so I can peek my manager when
he's showering how'd you end up working
with gucci mane I actually never thought
about that I was really surprised we
reached out we didn't expect him you
know to reply but he replied in two days
it was like yo let's go I can't wait to
tell you like my next collaboration you
have to choose a theme song to describe
your life what would it be Michael
Jackson dangerous what's your skin
skincare routine this is a fun fact when
a shower I clean my face at the very
last because shampoo and body wash
actually irritates your your your your
your skin can you leave a message for
your future self hanging there brother
it's gonna worth it work hard kiss me
one two three
you hate Google one two three I'm gonna
cut this out
I'm getting rejected by everyone that's
what come here wait isn't she the first
one thank you so much NS ALK these
puppies are adoptable you know what I'll
just I'll just do this wait for somebody
to kiss me
oh thanks for wiping off my makeup oh
thank you so much for having me by speed
[Music]